over the past few days we've received a
ton of new information on when we should
be expecting
the brand new 14 and 16 inch macbook pro
which is really exciting but
unfortunately
there's also some very bad news as most
of you know i made a bet that apple
would be revealing the m1x macbook pros
at this year's wwdc event
which happened last month but they
obviously never got released
my prediction was based on three main
things
the reports that said that we should be
expecting the macbook pros in the second
half of this year
and then the fact that apple revealed
their imac at the spring loaded event
but didn't start shipping them for an
entire month
and then the report that apple's next
apple silicon chip
has already begun mass production so i
basically combined all of that
info and made the claim that the macbook
pros would be announced at wwc
but wouldn't ship until july which is
the second half of the year
matching up to all of those reports
including a report from mark german
saying that we could see them launch as
early as this summer
but of course i was wrong and we later
found out that they were most likely
delayed
due to many led component shortages
which is
extremely disappointing so we made a
follow-up video where i
of course shaved my beard like i said i
would before discussing the
possibilities of one we could be seeing
the new macbook pros getting released
and we basically narrowed it down
to two different options the first and
most likely option was that apple would
host an event
in either october or november like they
did last year for the m1 mac event
which would of course really suck to
wait that long and the second option was
that apple would hold a surprise event
this summer
either in july or august just for the
new m1x macbook pro
which isn't as likely because apple
doesn't do summer events
and unfortunately a few days ago we got
some very bad news from mark german
who was basically the most reliable
apple leaker out there
if you consider his accuracy rating and
his vast number of leaks put together
he says that quote for apple all
attention is
on the fall so the next several weeks
are destined to be light
on product news and then he even said
stay tuned for plenty of news after the
summer
doldrums which basically means a state
of inactivity
stagnation or depression he went even
further
reminding people not to forget about the
mac with new macbook pros coming later
this year
so basically from his perspective he's
not expecting
any max from apple over the summer and
he's especially not expecting
any kind of summer apple event this is
pretty crappy news because as most of
you know
there's a tech drought going on right
now with basically nothing new to cover
especially from apple so that basically
leaves us with the most likely option
which is a mac event
in october or november but wait
we just got some brand new reports that
actually claim
that we're getting these macbook pros
sooner than expected
according to the economic daily news new
airpods and macbooks are due to launch
later this year
with apple suppliers apparently hurrying
to increase capacity
in preparation of new launches with
shipping momentum expected to be
significantly stronger from the third
quarter of the year
at the earliest which is in between july
and september and then getting even more
interesting digitimes reported that
apple is gonna launch
the 14 and 16 inch macbook pro late
in the third quarter and mac rumors
believes that it most likely means
it's going to happen in september which
is really odd
but then we can go back to report that
digitimes made
in early june which said that apple
would begin shipments of new macbook
pros
in the third quarter going even further
digitimes claim that apple is reportedly
spending
200 million dollars on other suppliers
to make sure that they have enough mini
led displays
for their upcoming 14 and 16 inch
macbook pros
which shows that they're in a rush to
get enough supply
and this totally lines up to earlier
reports way back in february and april
saying that these new macbook pros will
for sure be getting mini led displays
which some people recently started
doubting so apparently
the idea is that apple is going to be
revealing the new macbook pros
at their september iphone event which
sounds
extremely weird but it might actually
make sense
first off according to recent leaks the
iphone 13
might actually be called the 12s which
points to it not being that exciting of
an upgrade
especially since it seems like touch id
is no longer coming
until next year on top of that we
recently got bad news for the apple
watch series 7 as well
with any redesigns not expected to
happen until
next year which is extremely
disappointing so if apple ends up having
two products that don't get
any awesome or major updates people
might be extremely disappointed
with the september event and that's
obviously really bad news for apple so
there's a chance that they're going to
be revealing the new macbook pros
at the event itself to make sure it's an
awesome
and exciting event despite the
lackluster iphone
and apple watch updates and that would
fit perfectly in line with the reports
that claim that the new macbook pros
will be launching in the third quarter
of this year
and it'll also match up to what mark
german is expecting
with no new apple products until after
the summer
however i personally feel that these
macs deserve their
own mac related event because mixing the
announcements with iphones and
apple watches will seem a bit too
crowded so what if there's still a small
chance that apple does some sort of a
press release or mini event in august
with a launch date at the end of
september because on top of all of these
new products
we're actually expecting even more like
the airpods 3
which i believe are coming alongside the
new iphones at the september event
and i'm very confident about that
because in march of this year
dizzy times reported that new airpods
are expected to launch
in the third quarter which points to
september
and on top of that mark german said in
may that airpods 3 with a pro looking
design
will launch later this year and what
better time
than alongside the iphones and about a
week ago
digitimes reported that at least seven
apple suppliers
have kicked off component shipments for
upcoming apple products like the apple
watch
iphone and the 3rd gen airpods which
clearly shows
that they're all going to be releasing
at the same time and on top of that
we're expecting the ipad 9 to get
released as well
which can also be revealed at the
september event
so in my opinion it seems a bit too
crowded
to show off the macbook pros at the same
time as everything else
i personally think it makes more sense
for apple to either wait until october
or november for these macbook pros with
a small but
very unlikely chance that apple will
reveal them in
august with a launch in late september
however if apple waits until after the
iphone event
to reveal the new macbook pros this
brings up the question of what apple is
gonna be calling
the new chip that's going into those
macbook pros if they call it the m1x
it might seem weird to do that after
revealing the a15 chip
in the new iphones but it's gonna match
up to their usual naming scheme
and if they end up calling it the m2
chip it's going to be even more weird
because they're going to be the higher
end chips so the big question
is what will apple name the chip that's
going into the redesigned lower end
macbook air
i personally believe the m2 chip will be
very fitting for that lower end macbook
since it's also going to be perfectly
fitting for the 2022 ipad pro
which we just made a video about so in
my opinion apple is either gonna be
calling the new chip going into the
macbook pros
the m1x chip like we previously expected
or they're just gonna go straight to the
m2x
chip and then later when they reveal the
macbook air
they'll give that vm to chip yes that
sounds confusing
so i personally think the biggest bet is
that it's gonna come with the m1x chip
and it's gonna feature the same cores as
the m1 ship
which might seem weird after the a15
comes with newer cores
but hey we can all blame the chip
shortages for that
unless of course apple shocks everyone
at the end of the summer with a surprise
macbook pro reveal which obviously isn't
as likely
but it would surely be awesome to not
wait that long for new max
if you totally disagree with my thoughts
on the macbook pro release date
go ahead and comment your thoughts down
below but if you enjoyed this video
click that circle about to subscribe for
more videos like this one
definitely check out one of those two
videos right there thanks for watching
and we'll see you
in the next one